what go ahead say it I can feel judgment
emanating from your pores it's not
judgment it's a prize am I not allowed
to be surprised you're allowed to be
whatever you want I just don't want to
focus group this
you are not Progressive enough for this
Carrie Miranda and Charlotte get into a
fight and it's a doozy people it's
shocking it's shocking so Miranda
reveals that she's quit drinking on the
HBO Max Sex in the City Revival series
but she's still feeling all hot and
bothered just thinking about Carrie's
boss Che Diaz following their drunken
hookup of course Carrie already knows
but now Miranda's coming clean to
Charlotte about the whole steamy
incident and Charlotte she isn't having
it I'm gonna tell you something
and you're going to have a big reaction
and I'm asking you not to okay
I had sex with Che at Kerry's apartment
after the surgery when we thought she
was asleep
what you had a huge reaction oh of
course I was a huge reaction you you
knew you knew
something
cheese
and from there things only escalate with
the mom of two pointing out that Miranda
she's still married to Steve it is an
affair that's what it is it is not an
affair
so are you gay now no
I don't know it's not as simple as gay
or straight Jay identifies as non-binary
use whatever words you want but you
spent your whole life with men you're
married to a man and now you're suddenly
having non-binary sex it was the most
alive that I have felt in years of
course Miranda previously confessed to
Carrie that she's unhappy in her
marriage I'm unhappy
I'm unhappy
okay
I'm trapped
I hate my marriage I hate it
I hate my life I I hate it and when ET
chatted with Cynthia Nixon who plays
Miranda last month she teased one roller
coaster of a season we didn't come back
to be boring we didn't come back to do
stuff that we'd already done we came
back to to throw these characters into
new situations and let them you know
follow their hearts sometimes you know
mistake you know sometimes making
mistakes sometimes on the right path you
didn't like us because we were boring
the first time you liked us because we
took chances and that's what we're doing
and you know stick around there's a lot
to come and all that Echoes what Sarah
Jessica Parker told E.T at the show's
Premiere about exploring their
characters over a decade after the
release of the movie Sex in the City too
we felt excited about
the kind of stories that we were
interested in telling we were curious as
to you know about where they were and
who they were and what was their life
like and who were they now surrounded by
but back to that fight in the park
you're having a midlife crisis you
should have just dyed your hair
not helpful when Miranda tries to storm
off from their lunch Kerry refuses to
Let Her Go Miranda stop stop come on
stop stop stop we already lost Samantha
not losing anyone else people are gone
in a second you can you can disagree but
you can't leave
[Music]
I'm sorry
I just
I want to understand well when you do
maybe you can explain it to me what is
wrong with people just staying who they
were some of us don't have that luxury
fun fact Cynthia actually directed the
episode and posted a few behind the
scenes snaps on social media she
captioned the post in part quote to the
incredible cast and crew thank you for
welcoming me with such Open Arms to take
a seat in the director's chair cut
that great
the 55 year old actress also thinks the
show's Creator Michael Patrick King
ET recently sat down with the showrunner
who opened up about Reviving The Beloved
series you know it's a different world
and I thought how great to see these
familiar characters in the new world and
see where they are now just became the
right moment the right time to see them
all again when you have actresses like
Sarah Jessica Parker and Kristen Davis
and Cynthia Nixon they can play anything
and as a writer you make sure that they
play everything so the characters have
all grown like all people do through the
world so it's really exciting
[Music]